come on what came down though what came
down the crash the other trade center's
down it's down
it's down
[Music]
[Music]
so
we're back at 8 30 on this tuesday
morning it's the 11th day of september
the year 2001.
it is such a pretty morning isn't it
although it's not fall yet
[Music]
now some very very sketchy details
reaching us here at sky center important
enough to bring to you though at this
early stage we believe that a plane has
crashed into the world trade center in
new york right now we're getting
information out that it was a small
commuter plane and of course we'll let
people know as soon as we have more
information as to what actually caused
this and of course on everybody's mind
who was
[Music]
what we've just seen is is about the
most shocking videotape i've ever seen
what are the odds of two separate planes
it is completely impossible to
understand why this is happening and to
figure out what in the world is going
on we heard a big bang
and then we saw a small coming out and
everybody started running out and we saw
the plane on the other
side of the building and there was smoke
everywhere people are jumping out the
windows over there jumping out the
windows i guess because
they're trying to save themselves i
don't know blew up a big explosion
people started running it was just chaos
everywhere
people jumping out people just kept
jumping and jumping and jumping
[Music]
and now you you have to move from talk
about a possible accident to talk about
something deliberate let's go to
president bush right now
two airplanes
have crashed
into the world trade center
in an apparent terrorist attack on our
country
i have spoken to the vice president
to the governor of new york
to the director of the fbi
and have ordered that the full resources
of the federal government
go to help the victims and their
families
and to conduct a full-scale
investigation
to hunt down
and to find those folks
who committed this act
terrorism against our nation will not
stand
and now if you join me in a moment of
silence
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
we've forgotten somewhat to remind
people that there was the crash of
another plane a fourth plane outside
pittsburgh about 80 miles from
pittsburgh and we don't have video of
that story at the moment that's the
fourth prong in this terrorist attack on
u.s soil we want to just repeat those
airline numbers which is
you know extremely upsetting news for
people who have loved ones on these
flights but we want to give you that
information the four aircraft involved
[Music]
we described to you the possibility of
that north tower collapsing about five
minutes after we went off the air it did
collapse
once again we have no idea at this point
the loss of life i can only tell you
there were hundreds of emergency workers
down there about five or six blocks in
the first few minutes emergency workers
were trying just basically to get out of
there to survive you could see that
written in their faces the situation was
so desperate they just wanted to get out
of there
today our fellow citizens
our way of life our very freedom came
under attack
in a series of deliberate and deadly
terrorist acts
the victims were in airplanes
or in their offices
secretaries businessmen and women
military and federal workers
moms and dads
friends and neighbors
thousands of lives were suddenly ended
by evil
despicable acts of terror
the pictures of airplanes flying into
buildings
fires burning huge huge structures
collapsing
have filled us with disbelief
terrible sadness
and a quiet
unyielding anger
a great people has been moved to defend
a great nation
terrorist attacks can shake the
foundations of our biggest buildings
but they cannot touch the foundation of
america
[Music]
you